hola mi nombre es íñigo quiles y trabaje
en valiente haciendo todos los árboles
el bosque y los ambientes naturales de
la película y usé muchas matemáticas
para hacer esto
yo creo que muchas personas piensan en
las matemáticas como algo aburrido y
mecánico pero esa no es la forma en la
que vemos las matemáticas en pixar para
nosotros las matemáticas son una
herramienta para crear imágenes
movimiento viveza y diversión
en esta lección hablaremos sobre una de
las formas en que usamos las matemáticas
para crear los paisajes de valiente
empecemos con lo más sencillo que
podemos encontrar en este paisaje una
hoja de pasto una hoja de pasto es algo
que empieza en una punta crece en una
dirección y se inclina se parece a una
pequeña curva delgada estas son buenas
noticias porque en matemáticas tenemos
muchas herramientas para describir
curvas en este caso escogimos una
parábola que es una curva muy específica
sin embargo eso solo nos da la curva de
la hoja y aún tenemos que agregarle un
espesor y un color para que sea una hoja
de pasto y para poder llenar todo el
bosque necesitamos crear millones de
esas curvas y después darles los
espesores y colores correctos para crear
algo orgánico y natural quieren saber
más quédense con nosotros para el resto
de la lección